[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much thanks Paul thanks
Mike thank you all for being here
the book outside is as Paul noted called
the Sumter Gambit how the left is trying
to foment a civil war
and uh one thing that I have learned
over the last few months since it's been
out is that very few people know how to
pronounce foment foreign
but
and you'd think you know radio hosts and
they're talking about fermenting a civil
war
like what would that taste like my
goodness can you imagine the Brew but uh
when it comes to a civil war that is
exactly what the left is trying to do
they are trying to create a win-win
situation for themselves
and the win-win situation goes like this
push
the craziest most extreme most insane
things onto the public
like who five or ten years ago would
have thought oh pretty soon there'll be
drag queens in first grade classes and
you're a bigot and a hate Monger if you
think there's something wrong with that
and if you object
then you are branded an insurrectionist
and an FBI investigation is opened up
against you
and who knows what kind of misery would
follow that so so it's a win-win
situation for the left either we sit
back and we take all this
their radical social and cultural agenda
and their radical political agenda
or else if we fight back then they will
use that as confirmation of their false
claim that the right doesn't want a
constitutional republic and wants to
destroy it and create some kind of
dictatorship and crack down on the
insurrectionists so either way they win
whether we act or whether we just sit
back and accept it
now that's the Dilemma that they're
trying to create
there are all manner of ways in which it
might not work out for them
but it's useful in this time when we
have never been closer since the 1850s
and the beginning of the 1860s to a
civil war it's useful to look back at
how the first Civil War began and some
aspects of it in order to understand
where we are now
the Civil War in the first place if you
remember from history if they taught you
this so yeah they probably taught you
this they taught us this but the the
younger children don't know anything
about any of this the Civil War
began
because of a showdown
where one side blinked
it might have been avoidable but both
sides were trying to make the other side
start the war
and so they could then portray the other
side as the aggressor
what happened was various states of the
Union starting with South Carolina voted
to leave the union
now when that happened did the federal
troops pick up and leave those States no
they became Confederate troops
almost everybody was in favor in the
states that left of leaving and so the
military the the Confederate Army was
formed of Union troops who were in the
south
who followed the states into secession
in Charleston South Carolina in the
harbor
there was a fort
and the state of South Carolina Fort
Sumter and the state of South Carolina
voted to secede
in Fort Sumter the General in commend of
the fort was named Robert Anderson and
he was from Kentucky which was a border
state there were some people in Kentucky
who were favoring the South and some who
favored the north Anderson favored the
north so he did not
have his troops become Confederate
troops and the fort become a Confederate
Fort it remained a fort in the hands of
the government in Washington
now this created an awkward situation
because it used to be when it was all
One Big Happy Family the people in the
fort if they needed Provisions would get
in a boat and go over to Charleston and
buy what they needed
but now they couldn't do that because
Charleston was a foreign country that
claimed the fort
so
it became a standoff
the South made it very clear to the new
President Abraham Lincoln if you sent
troops send a boat to give supplies to
the Troops in the fort we will consider
that an act of War because the fort
belongs to us
and Lincoln thought okay so I can sit
back and take it and let them take the
fort because they'll starve out the the
troops that are there
or
I can resupply the fort
and a war may start
but he decided to resupply the Fort
because the war would only start if the
South fired when he resupplied it
meanwhile the South had the same kind of
dilemma
they either let them Supply the fort and
thus acknowledge that it wasn't really
theirs at all and that their claim to
have seceded was Hollow
or they fire on the fort and start the
war
so of course they fired on the fort they
started the war
and so then Lincoln could say for four
years we didn't want this war they fired
on us
but he couldn't let them go either
because of the fact that it was in a
real Insurrection not a January 6th
Insurrection and he had the
responsibility as president to put down
an insurrection
so
both sides were trying to outmaneuver
the other in the same way
and we see the left playing the same
kind of game today that they're trying
to maneuver us into a situation where we
either sit back and take it or if we
fight back then they use that against us
if it comes to a civil war though it
would be much worse than the first one
and we can all hope that it won't
because the fact is that in those days
there was one very
good fact
in all the terrible things that happened
at that time and that was that there was
a geographical division between the two
areas of the country that were at so at
odds with each other
this the this pro-slavery people were
all in the southern states and the
anti-slavery people were in the northern
states and so it was very neat
James Buchanan the president before
Lincoln as a matter of fact was willing
to let the South go and become a
separate country and make a clean break
and that would have been the end of it
probably would have led to a number of
other problems but that's another story
now
in the present period there's no such
geographical distinction you are living
testimony to that because you're here
tonight you are generally then probably
on the conservative side of the spectrum
you probably don't think very much of
Gavin Newsom or Joe Biden
and yet the people who do or at least
seem to they they are very much in
charge in California so what happens if
there's a civil war California goes with
the left side and then what do you all
do
and what we're looking at actually is
that if there is Civil War in the United
States as I hope there never will be
then it would be more like the Liberian
Civil War the Civil War in the West
African country of Liberia in the 1990s
than it would be like the American Civil
War in 1861. the Liberian Civil War was
extremely bloody and it was neighborhood
to neighborhood street to Street house
to house
and that's what it would be if it ever
came to that
we can hope it will never come to that
but unfortunately I have to give you
more bad news and that is that the
divisions in American society now are
much greater than they were in 1861.
in 1861
Abraham Lincoln could appeal and he did
several times
to
the Christian Bible and to Christian
principles because he knew that the vast
majority of people in the South and the
vast majority of people in the north
shared that perspective
and so even in his in his magnificent
it's a it's a rhetorical Masterpiece his
second inaugural address if you're not
familiar with it should go back and read
it it's it's one of the greatest
speeches ever given by anyone just in
terms of rhetoric but he can't resist
giving a little dig to the defeated
South at that point and said that uh
whether it's really reasonable to think
that a just God would want some people
to live by the sweat of the brow of
other people while they sit back this is
something that can be discussed but he
knew that that was a valid point for him
to make because they both had the same
worldview they both had the same
framework
both the North and the South were
generally Protestant Christians and they
looked at the world in the same way
days
that's not remotely true
you have Jews and Christians on the
right Jews and Christians on the left
and the biggest divide is not between
Judaism and Christianity or between
religion and Atheism it's between the
right and the left
and you have
right wing and left-wing Believers in
all the religious traditions
with one possible exception in Islam
that's another story too but I've
discussed that one enough the
[Music]
Division if it came to it today
it would be much wider and there would
be it would be a lot harder for a
president of the stature of Lincoln if
we ever have one to be able to find
anything common on which to appeal
we're talking about people with
radically different values with a
radically different view of the world
and radically different values I think
is nowhere clearer than in the
transgender controversy
where one side is saying you are going
to drive children to suicide
you are monsters who are not letting
people be who they really are
and you don't care how many of these
children die
and the other side says you're the
monsters that are mutilating
young people and making them think that
a life after this kind of Mutilation and
a life of dependency on Pharmaceuticals
and being at war with every cell in
their body is the way to become their
true selves
how can those two positions be possibly
reconciled that's an as as William
Seward
who was running for president in 1860
and was the front runner but was
surprisingly defeated for the Republican
nomination by Abraham Lincoln he said it
was an irrepressible conflict between
the North and the South and if that if
that was this is ten times more of an
irrepressible conflict
after the war however the Civil the
first Civil War
there was reconciliation and again in
that great speech the second inaugural
address of Abraham Lincoln he said that
we will bind up the nation's wounds with
malice toward none with charity to all
you have to understand this is while the
war is still going on it's almost over
it's very clear the south is defeated
but and and actually Grant and Lee have
already signed uh the the surrender of
the army of Northern Virginia but there
are others places where the fighting is
still going on
and there are people who are out for
Revenge who were being for the head of
Jefferson Davis and Robert E Lee and the
others and Lincoln is saying with malice
toward none and charity to all
it was an extraordinary thing to say
really
after a war and it was in that same
spirit that the famous and controversial
Confederate statues and con and military
bases named for confederate generals
came about
you'll be happy to know of course if you
don't know already that a national
commission has determined that uh any
anything involved with the U.S military
any forts
or any statues on Military property of
Confederates the forts will be renamed
the statues will be removed we're going
to spend millions of dollars to do this
over the next few years
and people are saying that these guys
who glorify glorified slavery and led us
into a bloody war to glorify slavery to
preserve slavery they don't deserve to
be named to have military bases named
after them and to have statues and so on
but nobody ever seems to stop and ask
why are those statues there in the first
place why were those forts named for
Bragg and Lee and Maxie and all the rest
of them why did these Confederate
generals get this honor of all these
things being named for them
the reason was actually National
reconciliation
and it came from a more mature and
complex understanding of human nature
than most people have today
and I see this in young people all the
time
and this is what they're taught in the
schools
that Robert E Lee
oh he fought for the South
he owned slaves oh he was evil
period 100 percent black or white that's
it
that kind of point of view actually
prevailed at the time that the war was
ending
and this is what Lincoln was arguing
against
do you know uh have you ever anybody
ever been to Arlington National Cemetery
yeah a lot of people where where uh the
military has the graves of some of the
Great
generals some of the Great
political figures of the of the American
of American history
and of course so many soldiers are
buried there do you know that it's
Robert E Lee's front yard
it was taken from him at the end of the
Civil War as an act of vengeance
that he had led the South into this led
the south in this war they were not
going to put the graves of all the
soldiers on his front lawn and make it a
cemetery
and rub it in
and that is of course the spirit that
prevails today
that there's no good in any of this but
when in the 1930s and 1940s
the American government actually agreed
to name Fort Bragg Fort Bragg and Fort
Hood Fort Hood and all the rest of them
after Confederate generals
they were not doing it because they were
racists and loved slavery that's the
line now that all this was really
because these people secretly wanted the
South to win and they hated blacks and
so they wanted to name these peop these
these monuments and forts after these
Confederates because they were
Confederate sympathizers
case that's not what happened
in many cases the impetus for these
names came from people in the north
these things were done because in those
days people understood that you could
have a general like Robert E Lee and he
could have many great Noble qualities of
courage and dignity and heroism
and still be a flawed human being
if you want to have a statue of an
unflawed human being you're not going to
you can't have any statues
and ultimately if you want to play the
canceled game you're going to cancel
everybody
because everyone has various flaws
and this was known in the days when the
statues went up
and it was understood that they could
say we can praise the good qualities of
these people without affirming that that
means that we thinking they were right
about the war or about slavery
and this will bring the nation together
now of course what they're doing now and
tearing them all down
is trying to tear the nation apart
not just by tarring these people as 100
evil because they fought for this cause
that was fighting for what is inarguably
an evil
but also because then they can make us
all ashamed of our culture and Heritage
in general
whether you are from the North or from
the south or whether your family came
here after the war and you had nothing
to do with it whatsoever it's part of
American History it's part of who we are
as Americans
and the reconciliation
that is manifested in the statues is
part of who we are as Americans
and so to tear it all down is to say no
to be an American it's a bad thing in
itself
it's evil in itself and you should have
nothing to think of in your past and
your cultural and political National
Heritage other than shame
because there is no good in America
and once they have taught a whole
generation about that
then who's going to want to defend the
United States if it were attacked
and so it's a very it's it's a very
clever scheme you got to give them
credit they've thought it all out very
carefully
planned it all out with Incredible
Precision but the idea is now widespread
among young people that America is some
uniquely evil entity when actually
America has been a uniquely remarkable
Beacon of human rights in the world this
is why those of us who are the children
of immigrants
came here why our families came here
because of what America is
so
the idea ultimately
is to make America more easy to tear
down
and this of course is not just limited
to Confederates I started with the
Confederates because nobody really wants
to defend them
we have all internalized to such a
degree the idea that well you know if if
you defend those guys then you must be a
racist or you must be like pro-slavery
even and so you lose you cut the moral
ground out from under yourself
but that's actually where we should
fight
one of the Arenas in which we should
because it's carries so much
significance for our national history in
terms of the national reconciliation and
the possibility of reconciliation and
the complexity of human experience that
means that even if we have a hero we
might understand that the hero is flawed
that's just the way the world is but
he's still a hero for these various ways
various reasons
the goal of course is
to replace all these people with their
own Heroes
and so after a while you know the
statues of George Floyd and the statues
of uh who knows Che Guevara and the rest
of them they're they're going to be
around to replace the statues that are
torn down but as I was saying it's not
just the Confederates if you go to
Monticello now Thomas Jefferson's home
in Northern Virginia
or James Madison's Montpelier also in
Northern Virginia
you're not going to get
you unless you try maybe turn off
everything they're telling you and read
up yourself before you go and don't read
the signs and don't follow the guided
tours you're not going to get Jefferson
and Madison you're going to get this was
a slave owner's house and here's where
the slaves lived and this is how the
slave suffered and this is why the slave
suffered because this rich white man was
over here
and he wrote This Racist Constitution
that enshrined slavery
and so you come out of that thinking wow
this was a very bad guy
we should torch this place down
and that's the idea
not to torch Monticello although I'm
sure that'll come eventually but to
torch the United States
to destroy it from within by weakening
its foundations
and weakening its foundations by making
people despise the people who created
them
and so this is the nature of the way the
Civil War actually is already being
fought
and so we have to understand that when
we're talking about history and the
Civil War in the present-day situation
uh
we should remember what Faulkner said
William Faulkner the novelist the past
is not dead it is not even past
and that is very true you know we're
still really in the post-civil War era
we're still reeling from the effects of
slavery in the free of the slaves and
everything else but it's extraordinarily
important that we not allow the left to
appropriate and rewrite
The History of the United States because
in doing so they are trying to fulfill
the adage of Lenin he who controls the
past controls the future
if they can make our past evil
then they can eradicate their foes
and have a free hand
now all this I understand is a little
bit of a little bit bleak
um I acknowledge that
and so I thought that I would end on a
an encouraging note
[Applause]
and the encouraging note is this you
ready
Robert F Kennedy Jr
now why do I say that I'm sure that he
and I have and probably all of us in
this room have a great many serious
political disagreements with him
but at the same time he demonstrates
he's a wonderful illustration of the
fact that history is unpredictable and
that it's full of surprises wonderful
surprises sometimes and he's the latest
in a string of things that I think that
the very powerful and very careful and
very strategic leftist cabal they didn't
count on
one was the first was brexit the the
people in England in Great Britain
voting to leave the European Union and
that's still playing out that's that too
is another story but it was a tremendous
blow against the globalist Socialists
internationalists Mega government that
they want to create
second of course was Donald Trump
now Donald Trump you know
uh I should publish a poll of what I
think of Donald Trump every day and it
would be going up and down like this
um and so I I don't want to say
I don't want to get it get into the
weeds too much about whether Donald
Trump is great or not or how great or
whether he should cut out picking on the
greatest governor in the country or
whatever else but the thing is that
nobody expected Donald Trump
nobody thought oh this billionaire
playboy real estate guy from New York is
gonna reveal the nature and the extent
of this leftist cabal that controls so
much that I mean did we know that before
I don't know if the many of us
maybe Joyce knew but very few people
knew before Donald Trump became
president just how deep the left's
control went and how much we were in
this thrall of a bureaucratic oligarchy
rather than actually having a
constitutional republic
but now it's all out in the open even in
his failures he smoked them out you know
because
they were so Avid to destroy and still
are
they had to reveal themselves in various
ways so you know when he became
president I was naive I thought oh he'll
Implement his agenda now I didn't
realize there was going to be this whole
entrenched bureaucracy of leftists
trying to stop him but now we know now
we know who's really running things
and so we can proceed accordingly
and their hegemony is not secure
and now the latest surprise is
this member of the most celebrated
political family in the country far
leftists who did more damage to the
United States over the last few years
than Ted Kennedy
his his uncle
and he himself has been a great advocate
for the climate change hoax and for any
number of other things
and yet now
here he is
I don't think he's going to be I hope
I'm wrong but I don't think he's going
to be the Democratic nominee I think
they're going to try everything they can
to stop him from getting widely uh known
but he's challenging the whole
establishment
in ways that I'm sure nobody expected
and you know everybody says well he's
spreading debunked conspiracy theories
about vaccines I read that in every
story about him and I think well you
know I might have taken that a lot more
seriously before this covet vaccine and
they said
you know it we were told it wasn't that
long ago you remember you'd get this one
shot and you won't get coveted boom and
then it was two shots and three shots
four shots five shots regular boosters
and you'll still get coveted but it
won't be as bad well it may be as bad
but you won't die well you'll die but
you'll go to heaven
appalling so I think maybe he's got a
point I don't know
and above all he said when he was when
he was announcing his candidacy that he
wants to challenge the state
and corporate power
that are working together
and I thought that's exactly it nobody's
talking about that I thought I was the
only one who was talking about that
RFK are you listening uh
really seriously in the book I talk
about fascism in the United States
fascism is you know communism is
ownership State ownership of the means
of production fascism they don't have
state ownership of the means of
production the state doesn't own the
means of production they're still in
private hands but the state tells the
means of production what to do
that's fascism and what is that but Joe
Biden's Administration working with
Twitter working with the other social
media Giants to censor dissidents about
covid and everything else
and
what is that but Joe Biden saying that
his opponent is the greatest threat to
the Republic
that's the way fascists talk
so he's Robert F Kennedy is talking
about this this is the conversation that
we need to have in America maybe we'll
have it now
so
we need to know where we are in order to
get where we need to be and that can be
disturbing and the situation can be
Bleak but remember that history is full
of surprises and that good things can
come from all manner of unlikely sources
I'm not saying that Kennedy is going to
get us out of all this but he's just an
indication that the road to Victory is
not assured for the left and they may
find all kinds of bumps in the road that
they didn't expect thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much Mike's coming
through with the microphone
that's why they call him Mike Mike right
so uh I agree with you 100 that history
teaches us that we don't learn from
history
okay and I'm also very glad that the end
that you said there's a glimmer of hope
because and I'm an optimist
uh
what I wanted to ask you is besides
talking about the Fascism and the
Communist I think there is another thing
that we need to bring into the
equation is the outside Source influence
that exerts enormous pressure
to divide the United States what is your
thought about the geopolitical situation
now and how the world is kind of
changing because of it I'm sorry I
didn't I don't think I caught exactly
the outside Source yes
oh well sure there are all kinds of
realignments going on because it looks
as if America is in Decline
very simply and these people can see it
as well as we can and so they think
America is no longer the world power and
we have to adjust to the new realities
and so there are Accords with China
Saudi Arabia making the Accord with Iran
at the behest of China
this is all part of the global
realignment and it's going to continue
certainly
um
so
so I'm not really sure what to say about
that actually the uh
it's unlikely to be reversed because
what Joe Biden has done well not really
Joe but the people who run Joe Biden has
what they've done over the last couple
of years is so severe that the damage is
going to take a long time to sort out
and so it may be that America will have
a diminished position on the global
stage
I don't see that being avoidable at this
point
okay Exquisite as usual Robert thank you
you know I'm wondering now with the
perverse love affair between Marx and
Muhammad
it
exposing the two are simply the same
monster wearing different garb is it
time to finally expose the this demonic
dimension of Islam and recognize it is
as wicked and as evil as it's at with
its new partner with a history of mass
murder throughout the centuries uh just
a narrative point of view we seem not to
be discussing that
I talk about it a lot
[Music]
actually yeah just the other day
actually uh I was discussing this Sunday
at the American Freedom Alliance
conference
that Karen Sigmund put on that was
really wonderful conference
and uh
yes it was it was superb in every way
yeah you're right though I think I'm
about the only person in the world
that's talking about it but yes there's
a tremendous congruence between
the left and Islam they love Islam for a
reason they don't just love Islam
because they're anti-racist and they
think that all Muslims are brown people
that's part of it for some maybe very
simple types but there are white Muslims
and it's not just that it's also that
they're both authoritarian forces that
are
deeply inhumane
they operate by A Reign of Terror
you have every time the left comes to
power there's a Reign of Terror going
back to the French Revolution that they
kill their enemies and they torture
people and sometimes they do it quite
arbitrarily solzhenitson and the gulag
archipelago says that they would just
arrest people for nothing
so that the rest of the population was
terrified and never knew and was deeply
afraid and always toeing the line
because they wanted to avoid being
arrested themselves
now
the reign of terror
corresponds to Islamic law
now you now you're going to say oh see
there he goes again that islamophobe
Islamic law is a beautiful system for
1400 years has been one of the abrahamic
religions anyway uh
the Islamic law is a Reign of Terror
really
their answer for everything
kill maim destroy
you you steal something cut off your
hand
commit adultery Stone to death
uh every last thing is
designed to terrify you into Towing the
line
and so
even in in in Islamic cultures
in Islamic countries there's a
tremendous amount of hypocrisy like
Ramadan just finished
there are so many accounts I have heard
of people getting caught sneaking food
during Ramadan and then they get beaten
thrashed killed any number of things
and it's not that the the they're
worried about God they're not worried
about Allah seeing them
they're just worried about somebody in
the Next Room seeing them
it's all done it's it's it's virtue that
is created by fear
the classical understanding of virtue in
the judeo-christian tradition is that
you do you choose the good because it's
good
that you do what's right because you
understand that it's the right thing but
in Islam it's just you do what Allah
says or else not Allah Allah yeah Allah
will roast you in hell yes and feed you
molten lead and all the rest of the
things that are in the Quran but in this
world you will suffer as well and the
Muslims will make sure of that
so they're both Reigns of Terror you see
and so they're both authoritarian
systems that operate on the basis of
fear
and so they have a deep kinship on that
on the basis
and this is why they love each other
and why there are cracks in the leftist
Islamic Alliance right now because there
are a lot of Muslims who think the
transgender business is madness and
they're very upset about it they don't
want it pushed on their children in
schools and a lot of Patriots I see
saying oh see oh this is great now we
can allow with those Muslims
well be very careful because it's not
going to make them think any better of
you
it's not going to make them discard what
Islam teaches about unbelievers
but anyway yeah Marxism and Muhammad
very similar we're going to go here then
Adele up front and then I think Gerald
has a question in the back
yes sir I am positive
by the support that this small crazy
minorities like sex changes and other
other
minor issues
of of minimum value to our society
get the support of the media
this is a person that I cannot
understand well I'll tell you very
quickly ilhan Omar told us in a
different context It's All About the
Benjamins uh
the
media is paid
it is not a news source
the New York Times CNN there have been
Revelations here and again more than one
of them being paid to promote a
particular angle and I am I'm confident
that that's just the tip of the iceberg
that these people are paid they are told
what line to follow and they follow it
and the companies the corporations fall
into line because of uh it's a Soros
funded organization called The Human
Rights Campaign
and the Human Rights Campaign is an LGBT
group and they have a corporate Equity
index CEI I think it's corporate Equity
index anyway they it's a it's a it's a
long
series of things like do you have gender
neutral restrooms in your in your
offices and things like that and you get
graded and corporations get graded
and if you get a low grade then you're
going to start to get boycotts and
pickets and angry editorials
and so the corporations fall into line
[Music]
well you know
yeah there's George Soros of course
everybody always mentions George Soros
in these connections but you know you
can't help but see his name keep popping
up and the Human Rights Campaign is part
of the open Society Foundation which is
a Soros organization
and he seems to have unlimited money I
don't know how exactly he gets it
operation what's that
well maybe it's the CIA behind him but I
wouldn't be surprised
Susan Rice has left the Biden
Administration I'm sorry Susan Rice has
left the Biden administration of Susan
Rice yeah supposedly to run for
president oh nice so I'm thinking she
puts herself out there Biden announced
today she winds up earning his VP they
push him out and she becomes president
Could Happen second possible what about
Kamala
oh
what do you think well I think that they
are very unhappy with Kamala
she didn't work out the way they
expected she's kind of an embarrassment
but you can't push her out because it
would be racist and sexist but Susan
Rice yes it's hard racist and sexist if
Susan Rice is replacing you I don't know
it's but I still think it would be tough
to have to find some reason you know
what she wants to spend more time with
her family
possible
ability too
conference well that would I think that
would be very fun to watch
I would I would hope that if that
happened that Trump would resign quickly
because I mean I'm sorry Trump is low on
my stock exchange right now but maybe
he'll rise up again Trump did great
things and he changed the whole uh
center of the discourse and got us
talking about things that the left
thought had been all settled you know
George W Bush was all for Mass migration
the Republicans even Ronald Reagan
signed the immigration amnesty everybody
was for Mass migration and then suddenly
Donald Trump's talking about building a
wall and how we have to restrict Mass
migration you know nobody was talking
about this do you remember Congressman
Tom tancredo
and he uh he went to Congress he was
going to fight against Mass migration
and try to get border controls and he
told me that nobody wanted to talk about
it on the Republican side
and that one time he got permission from
the caucus to show a five-minute video
of surveillance film from the border
that was just people strolling in but it
just never ended and you can imagine
five minutes you're watching people
crossing the border unimpeded and
illegally that's an awful lot of people
coming across and they never stopped
and he said that there were 200
congressmen in the room when the video
started and when the lights went up
there were three left
everybody just walked out nobody wanted
to talk about it so Trump completely
changed the discourse and now we can
talk about it again and talk about
immigration as a national security issue
The Strain on the economy the crime
everything else
and so then that's just one thing I
could go on and on about his great
things but at the same time
there's so much about what he did that
unfortunately
where he uh
appointed people who worked against him
I mean there's so many there's long
Litany of people if you read his truth
social uh messages where he says then
this this idiot and and and and and this
jerk and this and I think yeah but
these are people you appointed why did
you appoint them
anyway
that's why we've had a trump RFK ticket
I think okay flip it